[Music]
no one can say with any certainty what
happens after we die
and it's the one unknown all of us will
face
so
what if our existence wasn't temporary
what if there was life after death
how long can your brain live after you
die
could your loved ones still communicate
with you
and does your body contain the zombie
gene
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were life after death
according to a study in the year 2013
72
of americans believe in an afterlife
and some people like professor robert
lanza
have proposed a theory that death is
just a figment of our imagination
the theory states that death has no
actual boundaries that define it and
therefore
it just isn't real in the sense that
you've been trained to accept
we perceive the sky as blue but if the
cells in our brain
changed to make us think the sky was
green
our perception of reality could all be
faulty programming
so
is the sky blue or
is it all just in our heads
if our final moments on earth are all
just an illusion
does that mean you can come back from
death
at what point do you stop living and
become dead
first remember that death is a process
not an absolute and for 95 percent of
people the process starts when the heart
stops beating
after that your breathing stops and your
muscles lose tension
it's just a matter of time before your
brain shuts down but you're not on the
other side yet
a study called aware
awareness during resuscitation looked at
thousands of survivors of cardiac arrest
who had been pronounced dead
some of the people interviewed recalled
the exact moments of their death and
they reported seeing and hearing the
events leading to their resuscitations
how is that possible
well it turns out that your brain can
remain alive for up to 10 minutes after
your heart stops
that means you might hear the doctor
declaring you dead
nine percent of people who had a
near-death experience described floating
above their body tethered by an
invisible string
while you might hear everything going on
your body would remain dead without
oxygen or blood pumping to your organs
but
what would be going on inside you
well while rigor mortis sets in and your
muscles begin to stiffen
other cells would just be getting to
work
over the next 12 hours your body would
start to shut down fully
and during this time some genes
stimulate inflammatory cells called
glial cells to clean the inside of your
brain
these cells would continue to expand and
thrive while your body grows colder and
your other systems shut down
these zombie genes would grow arm-like
appendages and develop while the genes
in your brain disintegrate
but once you're dead
would your loved ones ever be able to
communicate with you again
before the development of infrared
photography seances were common among
family and friends who wanted to speak
to their dead loved ones
now we have the technology to prove a
fake spiritual encounter but
since we don't have definitive proof of
life after death it's understandable
that many people find peace in the
thought of talking to their dearly
departed
but what if we did have proof of what
happens after death
i mean if we could prove that something
else was waiting for us after we leave
our bodies
our perceptions of this life might grow
dim
but the end of our lives may not be a
spiritual experience at all
instead of seeing a white light
you might see ones and zeros
ray kerswell director of engineering at
google predicts that we could upload
digital copies of our brains online
if your consciousness was uploaded into
the cloud
your mind would live on as long as the
server lasts
so you might want to think of paying for
some backup storage
if we could prove that there is life
after death
you might view yourself and your life
with a renewed sense of wonder and
appreciation for what you have now
but
what if you didn't have the time to
appreciate your life on earth
what if you only lived for 24 hours
well that's a story
for another
what if